les enseignants de seine saint denis
reste mobilisé 70 % des établissements
sont en grève pour réclamer un plan de
rattrapage dans un département qu'ils
estiment sinistrés
tourcoing un jeu stupide de roulette
russe dégénérer en drame un lycéen et tu
rentres la vie et la mort après que son
camarade lui ai tiré une balle dans la
tête
le chômage en baisse - 7300 chômeurs en
février en france et demeure d'or
d'emploi s'adressent de plus en plus
souvent à des associations qui les
mettent en relation directe avec des
employeurs ont pays à découvrir les
nouvelles ruines mise à jour par les
chercheurs témoignage de la vie des
romains au début notre de notre ère
cinéma1 walt disney avec robin williams
flower un savant qui fait une découverte
qui lui colle aux doigts
madame monsieur bonsoir commencé il y a
trois semaines dans l'indifférence la
grève dans les établissements scolaires
dans le département de la seine saint
denis se poursuit et s'étend avec
régulièrement des manifestations à paris
dont la dernière en date a réuni cet
après midi un peu plus de 6000 personnes
les enseignants ce département qui
connaît de sérieux retards en matière
scolaire dans ces quartiers de banlieue
que l'on dit pudiquement défavorisés on
marche du défilé quelques veaux pour
briser des vitrines de magasins dans le
quartier du marché saint thonan
globalement les manifestants qui
défilaient cet après midi réclament pour
la seine saint denis un vrai programme
de rattrapage pour leur département
qu'il destine donc sinistrés sur le plan
scolaire jean bernard schmidt
jean louis blues comme chaque matin
depuis 30 ans jean-paul bazin se rend
dans l'établissement scolaire où il
lancé mais comme chaque matin depuis
trois semaines il ne fera pas cours à
ses élèves
pour ce professeur de physique et pour
la quasi-totalité de ses collègues
aujourd'hui encore c'est la grève
eh bien je pense qu'on aura des
discussions la nouvelle manifestation
prévue pour l'après midi
ici comme dans plus de 120
établissements anglais aime ses parents
et enseignants rejette le plan de
rattrapage pour la seine-saint-denis
présenté par claude allègre il réclame
plus de profs plus de surveillants et
des classes moins chargées pour beaucoup
de professeurs enseigner devient de plus
en plus difficile une situation souvent
décourageant je suis amer et à la limite
pas je regrette le passé parce que c'est
vrai qu'avant c'était gratifiant moi
j'avais des terminales par exemple quand
vous avez des terminales et que vous les
avez mené au bac avec succès eh bien
vous avez l'impression d'avoir fait
quelque chose
tandis qu'ici et bien sauf pour une
faible minorité des lèvres on a
l'impression qu'on sert pas tellement
parce que finalement ils sont peu
attentif y sont peu intéressés c'est ça
on a eu l'impression de ne servir à rien
patricia girard dit elle enseigne depuis
huit ans elle n'est pas aussi désabusé
que certains mais pour elle comme pour
les autres lorsque ces salles
aujourd'hui vide se remplissent délais
c'est à chaque fois un nouveau défi
maintenant quand on a des élèves en
classe qui n'est pas le cas ya huit ans
il faut déjà arriver à capter leur
attention les faire rentrer en classe
les calmes et les faire se déshabiller
la salle de classe pour eux c'est un
petit peu comme la cour de récréation
ils font pas la différence quand
l'enseignant pas ils font pas la
différence avec la télévision la radio
c'est un bruit de fond donc il faut
arriver a déjà restauré cette idée là de
l'adulte de l'école de l'enseignement
c'est vrai que c'est plus difficile au
quotidien c'est vrai qu'on ressort de
classe on est on est épuisés on a besoin
de s'arrêter parce que nerveusement
parlant c'est très éprouvant mais
maintenant c'est vrai aussi que quand on
arrive avec ces jeunes là on est
vraiment très très heureux
c'est pour la réussite de ces jeunes que
patricia et jean paul ont manifesté
aujourd'hui pour distille que soit
restaurée l'égalité à l'école à bagneux
dans les hauts-de-seine l'attitude du
principal d'un collège a mis en émoi un
certain nombre de parents d'élèves à la
suite du vol d'une clé donnant accès au
matériel informatique de l'établissement
le principal est d de la police a
procédé à une fouille séance de fouilles
faisant déshabiller les élèves la clé a
été retrouvé les ermites jacques
darniche 35 ordinateurs du matériel
vidéo
le collège henri barbusse est
particulièrement bien équipé
mardi dernier la clé qui ouvre toutes
ces sales disparaît c'est un vol et les
auteurs ne peuvent être des élèves de
quatrième as
après avoir tenté en vain de récupérer
cette clé par le dialogue
le principal fait appel à la police qui
pratique une fouille à corps sur les
quatorze adolescents
on les a obligés à baisser le slip et le
soutien-gorge et les garçons qui ont été
fouillés par des policiers hommes
on les a mis nu e on les a obligés à se
baisser et à tous et françois leyvraz on
était vraiment j'ai comme ça devant de
les femmes préfèrent pour connaissez pas
déjà
comme cette famille d'autres parents se
disent très choqué le principal
quand cette émotion mais estime que son
équipe a tout tenté pour éviter d'en
arriver là nous avons négocié pendant
une heure et demie avec les adolescents
comme nous faisons d'habitude en
utilisant toutes les techniques
particulières de médiation elles ont
échoué la proximité des vacances de
pâques avec un gardiennage et une
sécurité
- assurer pouvait nous laisser craindre
le pire
c'est à dire la disparition tout
simplement de notre outil pédagogique la
clé a finalement été retrouvé le
principal pense n'avoir fait que son
devoir faire impliquer respecter la loi
mais parce que la méthode a traumatisé
certains adolescents et parents
les substituts du procureur viendra
demain les rencontrer c'est un jeu
stupide entre deux copains qui a
dégénéré en bram dans un lycée de
tourcoing dans le nord un élève de 1ère
introduit ce matin en classe un pistolet
appartenant à son père et de boîtes de
cartouches
il applique larmes sur la tempe de son
camarade qui le met au défi de tirer la
suite
un jeune homme de 18 ans qui ce soir
lutte contre la mort marianne masse
patrick bertin un lycée en état de choc
cet après midi tous les témoins du drame
élèves et professeurs ont été prises en
charge par la cellule d'urgence
psychologique ça s'est passé comme ça
peut se passer dans ces circonstances
dramatiques comme ça c'est à dire que
des gens soumis à des traumatismes ont
besoin des cris en charge on va dire que
ça très précoce par l'intermédiaire
d'urgence médico psychologique du samu
c'est cette info
pendant deux heures après les faits les
élèves de la classe choqués n'ont
pratiquement pas pu parler c'est juste
avant midi que le drame s'est produit
pendant un cours de sciences naturelles
au fond de la classe à 5 18 ans est
assis à côté de son meilleur ami hassan
sort une arme et met son voisin au défi
de tir et l'autre tir à saintes
s'écroule
la classe est évacué puis l'auteur du
coup de feu bien raconter à mes lèvres
est venu spontanément me dire avoir
utilisé larmes qu'il avait été donnée
par les 20 30 qui lui est blessé qui lui
avait été donné sous la table on lui
disant tu peux essayer
elle est le cran de sécurité et ni
l'auteur du coup de feu a été placé en
garde à vue quand à cinq grièvement
blessé à la tête
il est actuellement au chr de lille dans
un état très critique d'après les
premiers témoignages
cela faisait plusieurs heures qu'il
jouait avec son arme un petit calibre
appartenant à son père mais personne n'a
rien vu
le lycée gambetta est un établissement
qui n'a jamais fait parler de lui pour
des problèmes de violence ce qui est de
la responsabilité de l'établissement
je ne vois pas en quoi dans l'état
actuel de nos informations elles
pourraient être engagées sauf à
prétendre que tous les enfants entrant à
l'école aujourd'hui doivent être fouillé
une arme est entré dans l'établissement
et comment des adultes peuvent-ils
laisser des armes à disposition de leurs
enfants
c'est encore la question que pose ce
drame les chiffres du chômage publiés
aujourd'hui font état d'une baisse de
0,2 pour cent en février au profit des
jeunes demandeurs d'emploi
principalement en partie grâce au
développement du travail intérimaire -
7302 murder demandeurs d'emploi donc en
février 3 millions 26 mille quatre cents
personnes sans emploi en france 12,1
pour cent de la population active
sur 12 mois le chômage a baissé de 2,1
pour cent et l'insee prévoit que le
mouvement de décrue va continuer dans
les mois à venir
pour autant la situation reste
contrastée selon les régions d'une ville
à l'autre en lorraine le fabricant
japonais de magnétoscope et téléviseurs
panasonic ferme ses portes à longwy où
il s'était installé dans les années 80
bénéficiant des différentes aides
françaises et européennes aujourd'hui ce
sont 130 emplois qui sont supprimés la
direction d'entreprises ayant décidé de
transporter ses fabrications en
allemagne les syndicats dénonçant ces
entreprises nomades qui se déplacent au
gré des subventions les plus
avantageuses reportages et christine
bost sylvain gauthier un crêpe noir qui
flotte sur l'enseigne panasonic ces
jours de deuil à longwy aujourd'hui est
jour de révolte contre le tout puissant
groupe japonais matsushita
écrite à l'encré rouge et rien n'entame
la détermination des longues officia qui
ont l'an iii en choeur résolu est grave
une poignée des 130 salariés de
panasonic sont venus encore une fois
exprimer leur colère leur écoeurement et
leurs désillusions après dix ans passés
dans la firme japonaise a semblé des
magnétoscopes jour de deuil puis de
travail presque pas d'avenir parce que
l'on retrouve du travail au niveau du
luxembourg 34 ans est trop vieux qui
bombe en france se trouvait croit ici
sur le site de longwy a plus rien
derrière
dans la région s'est vite c'est mort une
grande tristesse aussi grande tristesse
parce qu'on s'est battu jusqu'au bout
et puis pour viol a plus rien en fait
et il en va ainsi de ses usines
tournevis à la vie trop brève qui laisse
des salariés exemple jvc 243 personnes
sur le carreau depuis six mois
aujourd'hui 132 plus chez panasonic même
unis métal derniers bastions
sidérurgique du bassin de longwy va
supprimer 300 postes
de quoi faire réfléchir les pouvoirs
publics qui ont favorisé à coup de
primes
l'installation de ces usines à la sonic
a duré a duré neuf ans tu si vous voulez
a distribué évidemment plus de salaire
de rémunération et d'impôts locaux qui
n'ont reçu de prime mais faut
reconnaître qu'on se pose à juste titre
la question de savoir à quoi servent les
prix mais suffisent tel à enraciner une
entreprise dans un tissu local car il
s'agit de l'avenir de toute une région
orpheline d'un passé prestigieux
nous parlions il ya quelques minutes des
chiffres du chômage il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui en marge de la haine peut
se développe en france tout un marché de
l'offre et de la demande
journaux association qui offre d'emblée
des relation plus personnalisée entre
demandeurs d'emploi et entrepreneur
c'est notre enquête de ce soir laurent
bailly gens peuvent chausser
un journal un peu particulier l'emploi
en direct ne comporte que des demandes
d'emploi et il est livré chaque mois
directement au patron de quarante mille
entreprises en ile de france
grandes ou petites c'est l'emploi en
direct comme si jean michel billac c'est
bien lui le gérant que les abonnés soit
des chefs d'entreprise c'est bien cela
qui a intéressé brigitte bournazel au
chômage depuis un an elle recherchait un
poste équivalent à son ancien emploi
responsable d'une boutique de chocolats
mais elle n'a rien trouvé par l'anpe ni
par les petites annonces dans les
journaux classiques
alors quand elle est tombée par hasard
sur l'emploi en direct elle n'a pas
hésité une seconde
j'ai passé une annonce qui représenta
plutôt la mini cv c'est ce qui était
assez attrayant d'ailleurs quand peuvent
faire quelque chose d'un peu dynamique
d'un peu original par rapport aux
annonces tout bête entre dans certains
journaux et en fait quand j'ai fait une
annonce qu'il paraissait sympathique et
j'ai eu beaucoup de contacts en deux
mois émules et demie de temps j'ai pu
avoir une
12 and de contact différent et que des
contacts sérieux ça a marché
brigitte travaille aujourd'hui dans ce
magasin de thé son nouveau patron se
félicite d'avoir embauché par ce moyen
original
ce que j'ai trouvé très agréable dans le
fait de prendre de chercher un candidat
par le biais d'un journal de ce genre là
c'est que ça permet on allait coordonner
directement le numéro téléphone du
candidat ou de la candidate et que ça
permette fournisseurs de sélection
téléphonique de manière très souple
s'est pas vraiment à rendre c'est pas
aussi poser en cas rendez vous donc on
peut déjà testé un peu le candidat de
manière très naturelle
mais pour passer son annonce il faut
payer 360 francs pour trois parutions
ce n'est pas vraiment donné si on
compare ça par rapport à d'autres moyens
pour aller chercher un travail
vous pouvez envoyer des cv ou des ou des
lettres de candidature a beaucoup
d'entreprises si vous en voyez sans
l'être dans la nature ça vous coûte en
moyenne 5 francs ça va vous coûter 500
francs pour cent lettres
donc quelle est l'efficacité de la
technique que vous avez utilisé il y a
donc les demandes d'emploi mais surtout
il y a les offres que proposent les
associations
dans celle ci on s'occupe des cadres au
chômage c'est gratuit comme l'anpe mais
la grande différence c'est que la petite
équipe d'avec suit le demandeur d'emploi
de a à z
on arrive effectivement à personnaliser
un contact et à suivre chacun en
fonction de ses besoins
parce que tout est ajustée en fonction
de la demande certains donc pas du tout
envie d'être aidés et veulent juste de
venir consulter
puis juste peut-être euros ils sont sur
le point d'avoir un entretien là ils
nous demanderont le coup de pouce
relationnel qui là et c'est comme ça
qu'à 55 ans hermann schroeder un cadre
supérieur allemand qui vit en france
depuis 22 ans a retrouvé un emploi juste
que tu regardes ce dossier d'accord
après trente mois de chômage l'anpe ne
lui avait toujours rien trouvé
en six semaines l'association avec lui a
permis de rebondir ou 6,7 en fait comme
si j'avais conjoncture beau ceux
d'autres monteur et les autres moteurs
il faut pas les négliger
c'est aussi des landes que pour les
cadres apec dans nos mangas petites
annonces ou association avec ou sans
qualification brigitte et hermann n'ont
pas hésité à faire flèche de tout bois
pour retrouver un emploi les pêcheurs de
thon français de l'atlantique et de la
méditerranée en guerre contre bruxelles
qui veut dès le mois de juin prochain
interdire la pêche aux filets dérivants
c'est une bataille qui dure depuis plus
de sept ans maintenant entre les
pêcheurs et les écologistes qui reproche
à ses filets de porter un mauvais coup à
la faune marine principalement aux
dauphins cette décision européenne est
contestée par le gouvernement français
qui se fait l'écho de la colère des
patrons pêcheurs de l'île d'yeu par
exemple qui regroupe 25 des 50 thoniers
français qui pratiquent ce type de pêche
reportage jacques devaux gabriel camille
la flottille des fileyeurs de lille est
encore à quai mais dans les hangars on
prépare les filets pour la prochaine
campagne
ces fameux filet que les écologistes
accusent deux capturés accidentellement
des dauphins pour les pêcheurs ces
captures sont rarissimes
le fils est au contraire un engin de
pêche artisanat est filé une pirogue
peuvent être à filer un petit bateau
c'est l'engin du modeste c'est l'engin
du pauvre vouloir atterrir cet engin
c'est condamner des tas de régions dans
le monde et si l'europe prenez la
croisade d'interdire affilée pourquoi
demain telle ou telle région du monde
interdirait pas en atlantique
ils sont une cinquantaine de bateaux
français a traqué le thon blanc durant
l'été la moitié vient de l'île d'yeu
les captures sont relativement faibles
2500 tonnes les espagnols qui pêchent à
la ligne en capture d'une fois plus si
j'avais le fait que la pêche au thon
combat tout ce qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va tous se retrouver après sur les
côtes françaises
hélas le pulse stocks de poissons guy
hoquet déjà blasé on va finir
complètement écroulé sur l'île d'yeu
c'est aussi toute une économie qui est
menacée sur 5000 habitants de
ils vivent de la pêche et le ton
représente le tiers du chiffre
d'affaires
abandonner cette pêche c'est accepter de
voir se transformer l'île nous sommes
ali dieu sans fausse modestie des
dernières ile de france avoir une
identité de pêche forte à l'île d'yeu
ce n'est pas je dirais un cimetière
l'hiver et un parking à touristes l'été
l'île d'yeu est une vie ces marins
pêcheurs et nous voulons demain encore
pêcher malgré je dirais ce débat
complètement hypocrite et malhonnête de
l'europe actuellement
les îliens ne se laisseront pas faire et
ils le disent haut et fort pas question
d'abandonner une pêche pratiquée depuis
un siècle et qui fait la richesse de
l'île à bruxelles encore aujourd'hui le
ministre de l'agriculture français était
venu défendre les intérêts de nos
agriculteurs qui n'accepte pas la baisse
des aides global compenser en partie
seulement par des aides directes de tous
pour faire face à la concurrence
internationale
pour la première fois aujourd'hui et
pour bien montrer que les ministres ne
trahissait pas leur parole
les débats étaient retransmis en direct
premiers intéressés
le patron des agriculteurs de la fnsea
qui avaient fait le voyage reportage
jean yves perrin vincent maillard des
forces de police contenant une
manifestation d'agriculteurs
rien de très surprenant quand on parle
réforme de la politique à l'école à
bruxelles
le curieux la présence du ministre
allemand d'agriculture ont vomi lieu du
rassemblement
c'est qu'il est très fâché après la
commission monsieur bourges chartres
comme une majorité de ses collègues
européens ministre français en tête qui
lors du débat public une première en
matière d'agriculture a mis les points
sur les i cette proposition n'est pas
une véritable réforme de la politique
agricole commune mais la reprise de ce
qui a été fait en 92 en accentuant
l'importance de la baisse des prix
garantis et en augmentant le montant des
compensations sans que des solutions
nouvelles soit proposée les français
voudraient que les aides directes
versées par l'europe aux agriculteurs ne
soit plus lié exclusivement aux hectares
qu'ils exploitent
mais aussi aux fonctions non agricoles
qu'ils assument comme la qualité de leur
production ou l'entretien de l'espace
leval le ministre l'agriculture était
plutôt en phase avec les agriculteurs
que nous représentons may encore du
travail à faire et nous n'attendons part
du ministre qui fasse volte face ni
qu'il fasse marche arrière et nous
sommes là à le cheville
les négociations devraient durer au
moins un an pour laisser passer les
élections allemandes en septembre puis
pour mettre tout le monde d'accord
et là il ya du travail voyant là public
poursuit ses consultations sur la
modernisation de la vie politique en
france et notamment le mode de scrutin
aux élections régionales par exemple il
a notamment reçu aujourd'hui philippe
séguin le président du rpr pour lui le
président veut que l'on traite des vrais
problèmes des français
sécurité justice droit au travail au
logement plus pour alain madelin de
démocratie libérale la france doit
procéder à une profonde réforme des
institutions
enfin autre invité dominique voynet qui
indiquait au nom des verts au président
que pour son mouvement les écologistes
et bien un système mixte proportionnelle
majoritaire comme c'est le cas en
allemagne était la meilleure solution
pour éviter toutes les combinaisons il
permettrait une représentation de toutes
les forces politiques du pays avant
dernière journée du procès de maurice
papon à bordeaux son avocat jean-marc
varaut a plaidé l'acquittement car pour
lui l'accusé n'a joué aucun rôle actif
auprès des autorités allemandes
dominique verdeilhan patrick
descheemaecker
à la veille du verdict tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il ne faut rien
rater
patientez prendre un sandwich pour ne
pas rater une miette de la plaidoirie de
maître varrault prendre de la hauteur
pour ne pas rater
l'image prendre des forces pour tenir 16
heures pour convaincre m e varaut prend
son temps il veut répondre à 24
plaidoiries des parties civiles deux
jours de réquisitoire six mois de procès
16 ans l'instruction la défense joue le
tout pour le tout et abat toutes ses
cartes
contrairement à tous ville miliciens
dit-il papon n'a pas adhéré à la volonté
d'extermination cattrall l'avocat
s'indigne à voix haute
quel monde entre papon et touvier
l'avocat dissèque les huit convois et
conclut papon n'a été que le témoin de
ces moments dramatiques
ok aucun convoi n'était due qu'à ils
étaient tous trois occupants quand sa
particulièrement les enfants vous avez
dit il c'est un peu la croix se croit
c'est à cause des enfants mais pas à
cause de maurice papon qui n'était en
rien impliqué on écoute m e varaut mais
là il reste toujours attiré par maurice
papon filmé ici à l'heure du déjeuner
dans un restaurant bordelais à
l'audience l'accusé peaufinent les
derniers mots qu'il devrait prononcer
demain à l'intention des jurés
maurice papon s'est installé il prend
des notes voit quelques gorgées d'eau
consulte ses dossiers disposé devant lui
image étonnant d'un homme qui a
transformé son box en bureau comme ce
fut le cas pour le procès de klaus
barbie a lyon les cinq mois des débats
qui ont eu lieu devant les assises de
bordeaux ont été entièrement filmé et
enregistré plus de 500 heures qui vont
rejoindre les archives nationales pour
50 ans avant de pouvoir être diffusé
françois privat philippe demael des
cassettes vidéo très protégé l'opération
se déroule discrètement quelques minutes
après l'audience
rapidement les enregistrements de la
plaidoirie m e varaut sont emportés hors
du palais dans une salle des archives
municipales de bordeaux surveillé 24
heures sur 24
derrière ces murs aucune caméra nette
autorisés à filmer les débats
enfin presque depuis six mois le
réalisateur philippe la brune et son
équipe ont enregistré la totalité du
procès durée du film
plus de 500 heures le très gros plan a
été bannie simplement pour ne pas
accentuer atteindra la dramatique
aucun artifice aucun artifice pour
accentuer la dramatique mais quand il
s'agit de restituer une émotion
on doit être présent notre caméra
étaient toujours présentes sont maurice
papon
quand il fallait la passe à l'antenne on
l'a pas certaine je la passe à l'antenne
en ayant toujours en tête ce qui avait
été décidé auparavant avec le président
nathalie et scripts son travail noter
scrupuleusement le nom de chaque
intervenant et la durée des prises de
parole c'est un peu tranquille qu'on
peut savoir
tél
qui a pris la parole combien de temps
quand même pantel témoin a pris la
parole par qui il a été interrogé
la consultation de ces documents bientôt
stockées aux archives nationales ne sera
pas possible avant 20 ans 50 ans pour
des copies ou des diffusions sauf
autorisation spéciale pour les
infractions si vous voulez de crimes
contre l'humanité sur autorisation
toujours du président le tribunal de
grande instance de paris l'autorisation
peut être délivré immédiatement et ce
film pour l'histoire aura coûté un peu
plus de 5 millions de francs
affaire des écoutes de l'élysée opérait
sous lé second septennat de françois
mitterrand le premier ministre lionel
jospin dit qu'il refuse la demande de
levée globale du secret défense sur
cette affaire
il agira au cas par cas dix militants
présumés de mouvements nationalistes
corses ont été arrêtés aujourd'hui sont
interrogés dans le cadre de la sphère du
dynamitage de l'immeuble de france
télécom à ajaccio en octobre 96 le
bâtiment avait été entièrement soufflés
par une charge explosive explosive de
100 kg samedi dernier sur une route du
loir-et-cher deux enfants de 3 et 7 ans
qui circulait en voiture en compagnie de
leur maman ont été kidnappés par un
véritable commando de cinq à sept hommes
venus d'allemagne sans doute sur les
indications du père de nationalité
allemande qui vit séparé de sa femme
l'afer est arrivé aujourd'hui sur le
bureau du ministre de la justice
elisabeth guigou qui a décidé
d'intervenir auprès de son collègue
allemand pour que les enfants soient
rendues le plus rapidement possible
mathieu chez et diego garcia cosette
lancelin était sur cette petite route de
campagne avec ses deux enfants samedi
dernier elle rentrait chez ses parents
trois voitures en travers de la chaussée
l'obligent à s'arrêter une opération
commando rondement menée en quelques
minutes ses enfants sont kidnappés
mon fils qui était juste là me disait
maman maman maman m'a fait lit ma fille
ne trouvait pas de groupe pour dire ce
qui se passait en elles et ils ont sauté
dans la voiture l'autre qui était de
l'autre côté est aussi entrée sur est
aussi monté dans la voiture
j'essayais de par un vent d espoir de
leur arracher la clé dément je vais bien
sûr pas réussi c'était peine perdue ils
ont repoussé violemment sur la route
un kidnapping un peu particulier mathias
et caroline ont été enlevées par leur
père mari un allemand causette a quitté
son mari et l'allemagne l'été dernier en
attendant le divorce
la gendarmerie avait déjà été alertés
pour une première tentative d'enlèvement
mois d'octobre 1997
cette dame avait confiée à la brigade de
montoir son inquiétude de voir des
personnes rodez à la sortie de l'école
et la gendarmerie est intervenue pour
mettre fin à ce que l'on peut appeler
une tentative d'enlèvement
puisque nous avions affaire à deux
détectives privés qui venait sur les
instructions du mari essayait de
récupérer les deux enfants la mère
s'appuient sur un jugement du tribunal
d'orléans lui confiant la garde des
enfants
mais le père s'appuie lui sur un autre
jugement prononcé en allemagne lui
reconnaissant le même droit
quand je venais les voir en france quand
je leur parlais au téléphone il me
disait s'il te plaît va pas il m'a bilan
revenant nous à la maison bien arrosée
je leur avais promis j'ai éduqué mes
enfants de sauf d'aucune promesse doit
toujours être un nombre oublié ou
juridiques dont les enfants font les
frais le ministre de la justice
elisabeth guigou a reconnu aujourd'hui
la nécessité de rapprocher les
législations entre pays européens
il faut savoir que ce type d'enlèvement
n'est pas aussi isolé qu'on peut
l'imaginer l'année dernière les
statistiques officielles révèlent 268
cas d'enlèvement d'enfant par leurs
pairs l'association médecins du monde a
lancé aujourd'hui à paris un nouveau
programme des deux toxicomanes pour les
consommateurs d'héroïne il existe un
effectivement un traitement médical par
le biais de
médicaments de substitution appelé la
méthadone le problème c'est que ces
drogués sont le plus souvent tellement
marginalisés qui ne se rendent pas dans
les centres de traitement
l'association a donc décidé d'équiper un
autobus qui va parcourir la capitale à
leur rencontre jean marie n'est et
jean-louis mais là c'était méthadone
c'est un produit de substitution c'est
un produit qui enlève le manque chez
quelqu un qui arrête de prendre de
l'héroïne qui arrêtent de prendre un
produits opiacés pour remplacer
l'héroïne la méthadone première étape du
sevrage a fait ses preuves mais certains
toxicomanes sont trop marginalisés ils
ne se rendent plus dans les centres qui
en délivre alors à l'initiative de
médecins du monde
c'est la méthadone qui ira au devant de
ceux qui en ont besoin
18ème arrondissement le bus va
stationner une heure une trentaine de
personnes sont là qui attendent le
médecin nous nous adressons plus
particulièrement à des usagers droits
qui sont très marginalisées très
précarisés et qu'ils ont
une envie de soins mais ne sont pas à
même de faire la démarche
une seule restriction le produit n'est
pas délivrée lors du premier contact un
entretien poussée est obligatoire mais
par la suite tout passe par le bus la
dose est uniforme 40 milligrammes de
quoi lutter contre le manque permet de
ne pas avoir de douleur de me réveiller
de me réveiller normal le matin de
d'avoir trois repas par jour tous les
jours de pouvoir communiquer avec mes
proches sans avoir à me prendre la tête
sur à quelle heure je vais chercher ma
dose d'héroïne où je vais la trouver où
je vais trouver l'argent pour ça et ça
m'évite la délinquance aussi le bus sera
présent tous les jours de l'année
l'expérience financé essentiellement par
le ministère de la santé mobilise dix
personnes à temps plein médecins du
monde s'est donné six mois pour en tirer
un premier bilan
mais que l'été internationale face à la
montée de la violence les états unis on
l'a vu encore hier multiplie les
condamnations à mort en russie le
gouvernement a accepté un moratoire de
trois ans sur la peine capitale ce qui
aboutit concrètement à voir toutes ces
peine capitale commuée en réclusion à
perpétuité seulement voilà le paradoxe
veut que ces détenus emprisonnés dans
des conditions souvent à la limite du
supportable en viennent même à réclamer
le châtiment finale pour abréger leurs
souffrances
reportage dans l'une des plus terribles
centrale pénitentiaire de russie sur
l'île du feu un mille kilomètres au nord
de moscou moscou jean raby colonie
pénitentiaire un régime spécial de l'île
du feu près de vologda à 1000 km au nord
de moscou
une prison pour condamner à mort dont la
peine a été commuée en perpétuité
depuis l'entrée de la russie au conseil
de l'europe l'an dernier ils sont 127
condamné entre 25 et 35 ans sauf deux
qui ont 60 ans tous ont commis au moins
3 meur le régime de ce couloir de la
mort version russe est encore plus dur
que celui des anciens goulag soviétique
si dur qu'un condamné à mort sur quatre
refuse à perpétuité et demande à être
exécuté bien sûr que c'est mieux d'être
exécuté un condamné à vie c'est la pire
cruauté si la condamnation à mort et
exécutés bon ok d'une minute de peur et
de souffrance
et puis tout est fini pour eux être
condamné à vie c'est pire que d'être
condamné à mort qui réclament qu'on leur
tire une balle dans la nuque ou sans
avertissement selon l'ancienne pratique
ce midi j'étais content d'être condamné
à mordelles le muba peine en prison à
vie
c'est le directeur qui a rédigé à ma
place tout recours en grâce
moi je n'ai rien dit qu'il a dit j'ai
demandé au mexique
ce n'est pas un cachot c'est la
promenade une cage de 4 mètres sur
quatre ils n'ont pas le droit de se
croiser de se toucher ni de se parler
les suicides sont fréquents trois
tentatives le mois dernier dont une
réussie au cimetière gardiens et détenus
sont enterrés dans la même terre
mais les tombes de détenus restent
anonymes pour l'éternité
un détenu demande d'être exécuté il doit
être fusillés il doit avoir le droit à
la mort on est le moratoire sur la peine
de mort du président leur enlève
justement ce droit à la mort 28 condamné
sur 127 ont refusé tout recours en grâce
rien dans le droit russe actuelle me
permet légalement de leur refuser la
mort pour ces condamnés à vie les
intentions humanitaires de l'europe sont
une torture à la découverte maintenant
d'un lieu pourtant connu du monde entier
la ville de pompéi en italie réduite à
néant par l'éruption du vésuve en l'an
79 de notre ère deux mille ans plus tard
eh bien les chercheurs continuent de
découvrir des vestiges de cette ville
romaine englouti en quelques minutes
sous des tonnes de l'as rome à chalon
celle-ci laporte cache un des chantiers
archéologiques et plus importants
d'italie le seul en cours à pompéi
c'était une ville la belle grande
appartenant à boulange
un boulanger fortunés qui avait
plusieurs chevaux dont on a retrouvé les
squelettes tels qu'ils ont été saisis
par l'éruption du vésuve le 24 août 79
un boulanger qui avait aussi du coup
toutes les pièces sont décorées joliment
sobre
mais disons que la caractéristique
principale du maître de maison était
d'être un bon vie quand on l'a retrouvé
beaucoup d'enfants vide relief sans
doute d'une fête qui se déroulait ici au
moment du cataclysme
nous avons trouvé de ces petits
coquillages de ces mollusques que l'on
mangé cru à l'occasion des fêtes et que
le jeter par terre on se prend
maintenant on ne faisait pas que boire
et manger dans ce triclinium la salle à
manger
c'est vrai est magnifiquement conservés
montre bien que les orgies romaines
n'était pas un mythe
le chantier est loin d'être terminée et
il risque d'être le dernier avant
longtemps
le principal problème de pompéi est en
effet de conserver l'acquis un acquis
aujourd'hui menacé par l'air la
pollution et deux millions de touristes
qui visitent le site chaque année
quand nous aurons réussi à assurer la
transmission à nos descendants d'une
cité de pompéi solidement restaurer
alors et seulement à ce moment là nous
pourrons penser à faire de nouvelles
découvertes c'est dire qu'il reste du
travail pour les générations futures
sur les 62 hectares que couvrez-la
pompéi antique matière reste entièrement
à découvrir ce sport l'équipe
professionnelle le football de leeds en
angleterre a frôlé la catastrophe à son
décollage de l'ombre la nuit dernière
l'avion qui transportait l'équipe s'est
élevé de 50 mètres environ avant de se
rabattre brutalement en bout de piste
heureusement il n'y a pas de blessé et
puisque nous parlons football à un
consultant de marque pour le mondial
pour france télévisions notre président
xavier gouyou-beauchamps a signé un
contrat avec le roi pelé ni plus ni
moins parmi les films de cette semaine
sur nos écrans en france robin williams
dans flower
dans cette production des studios walt
disney il incarne un savant un peu un
professeur nimbus confronté à une
découverte révolutionnaire qui lui colle
aux doigts
pascal deschamps
flaubert climber en anglais llagonne
volantes et la dernière invention du
professeur reinhard un doux rêveur
solitaire
conçu dans le plus grand secret flaubert
ressemble à un gros bonbon gélatineux
mais renferme une énergie
révolutionnaire
flower permet à toute chose d'échapper
aux lois de la pesanteur le gentil
professeur devra se battre avec une
ribambelle de méchant qui veut lui
piquer sa géniale invention
voilà pour le scénario mais le plaisir
vient surtout de la confrontation entre
un flambeur conçu sur ordinateur est
l'un des acteurs les plus expressifs de
sa génération
salut c'est mime marceau bienvenus robin
est un mime extraordinaire il arrive à
faire croire que ça tient vraiment
quelque chose dans ses mains
suspects ni aux caisses sipa le monde
ont maintenant vous avez les antilles
alors dans sweeney never know na li au
look into you give me all night clubbers
je le mets dans match je vais me jeter
par la fenêtre et me laisser tomber
et quand je toucherai le seul ce
flambeur me renverra à mon point de
départ un ben je reviens donc trois
distingue movie d'un trio picasso
flaubert est un film familial dans la
tradition disney avec comme toujours ces
petits morceaux de bravoure qui font que
même les parents y trouvent à chaque
fois leur plaisir
retour sur la cérémonie des 7 d'or
d'hier soir france télévisions à
l'honneur hier soir hervé baslé d'abord
récompensé trois fois pour la série
entre terre et mer diffusé sur france 2
bruno masure meilleur présentateur et
puis aussi patrick chêne pour ses
commentaires sur le tour de france
savoir plus santé meilleur magazine de
la connaissance pour notre cause et
martin arenos pour france 3 les
minikeums ni meilleure émission
l'animation jeunesse et puis georges
pernoud une nouvelle fois récompensée
pour son magazine thalassa voile avant
de nous quitter le rappel des principaux
titres de l'actualité d'abord les
enseignants de seine-saint-denis qui
reste mobilisé 70 % des établissements
sont en grève pour réclamer un plan de
rattrapage dans un département qui
faisait screen sinistrés moins 0,2 pour
cent le chômage est en baisse en février
- 7300 chômeurs en france les demandeurs
d'emploi on l'a vu dans notre enquête
sata s'adresse de plus en plus souvent à
des associations qui les mettent en
relation directe avec des employeurs
dans un instant la météo sophie davant
20h50 un fauteuil pour deux avec eddie
murphy suivi de ça se discute présentée
par jean-luc delarue thème ce soir
jusqu'à une rencontre peut-elle changer
une vie demain dans les 4 vérités
marie pierre farkas possédera thierry
fournier président de la fédération des
parents d'élèves de seine-saint-denis
voilà je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre chaîne bonsoir à demain
il